I am convinced by the complaining that's
in the market convinced that we are well
on our way I don't know where we are but
we lost like just so you guys know I
want this on the record I want to look
back at this America lost we lost it's
like and by the way it's not because
like I love America more than breathing
it's because we're just too far along
and having our run and you could just
see it
those gap guys stand up you guys I love
you guys you always come my books let's
clap it up for these guys
I want you guys um I want well listen
you better [ __ ] take care of your
health because I need some more time and
you're old so get your [ __ ] together
sugar right if you think those guys from
that generation want to hear your
[ __ ] whining that you don't have
time go [ __ ] yourself that's but but
honestly I'm real serious about this
please please go talk to you if you're
lucky enough I'm not you know I I don't
I didn't grow up really with
grandparents except for one and now
she's sick and it's tough like go talk
to your grandparents and go ask them to
introduce you to four or five of their
friends and go ask them how they rolled
in life like what was tough when there
was war and [ __ ] depressions and real
[ __ ] and you're crying that you don't
have a thousand [ __ ] periscope
followers cut the [ __ ] out of here